did you hear about super fish this year
right yes this is the Lenovo laptop
scandal isn't it yeah this is this is a
better software that was installed on
pretty much every consumer a nuovo
laptop that it was so bad that the US
Department of Homeland Security issued
an advisory saying this needs to be
uninstalled and to understand why it's
so bad we need to understand
man-in-the-middle attacks there have
been a lot of techniques for
intercepting traffic for a long long
time one of the earliest ones I remember
is it's called ARP spoofing or ARP
poisoning so you've got your looter
sitting in the middle because all
looters have a little aerial and and
some lights on them and you've got
computers you know connected to this and
what you do is you you bring your
computer along to an open Wi-Fi network
something like that connect your
computer and your computer just
announcer's hello
I nailed a router I'm simplifying
massively here but basically the network
is built on trust
and so the computers just kind of
believe it and so the computers and the
router are sending all their packets to
you first and then you're forwarding
them on to the right location so
everything is going through you and
10-15 years ago this was terrible
because pretty much everything was sent
in plaintext email passwords websites
everything was going through in plain
text so you just sit there and provide
your computer as fast nothing in network
card was good enough you could see every
bit of traffic on this network I just
kind of slur fault passwords out
obviously massively illegal without the
consent of everyone on the network so
don't do that
um but I mean the solution to that is
SSL your computer sitting here and the
the server out here because all servers
look like computers from the 1990s your
computer sends a request saying hello I
would like to talk securely this is the
protocols I can support this if this is
my details and the server sends back
yeah ok here is my public key uh and no
computer filers has done you've done
public and private key before yeah he
sat behind me so yeah go watch his video
about public and private
trip now if you if you want other
details that basically the server sends
back a long series of numbers that your
computer can sign messages with these
and encrypt messages with these and they
can only be unlocked by that server
because maths I'm not good Ryan
explained more than that you can lock
messages only they can unlock them which
is great because because your attacker
who is sitting in the middle here and
reading everything will just see noise
except all we've really done is move the
problem back a stage because that first
bit that that hello I would like to talk
securely okay here's my private key that
has to go and plaintext and some in the
middle can change that they can take
that that public key that was sent by
the server and just go no I'm gonna have
that here's my public key instead you're
actually going here and then here your
computer here it doesn't know the
difference it then encrypts the message
with the attackers public key sends it
back here attacker opens it decrypt it
reads it yeah goes okay and then sends
the message that should have been sent
from your computer or properly encrypted
server goes alright we've got an
encrypted connection going on here sends
the encrypted packet the attacker who
can do this now unlocks it goes yeah all
right and then re encrypt it with their
key sends it on to you and now every
single communication is going through
the attacker no one knows anything is
wrong that is you that's your classic
man-in-the-middle attack the solution to
this is something called signed
certificates and this is why setting up
a secure server on the web casts a
little bit of money right now I mean it
may not in future the Electronic
Frontier Foundation and Mozilla are
trying to set up a thing to make this
free hopefully by the end of the year it
will be um but the idea is that there is
a third party vouching for the set of
public keys that you're exchanging I've
had to do this so I set up a secure
server about the year hook on hell what
I have to do is I when I'm setting it up
on time being right there it's going to
run this website it's going to be on
this address it's going to use these
protocols and now they generate this set
of public and private keys and then over
an existing secure connection one that I
knew to be good
I send that private key off to something
called a certificate how do I draw a
certificate authority I think it's going
to be a faceless office or why don't we
do a factory and then we know that
that's kind of industry going to the
Internet factory there we go the factory
of a factory of the inter yeah all right
we're there we go we got a padlock
factory there no it's not a padlock I've
drawn a padlock it's not it's a set of
keys this is what they called public and
private keys i generate my keys I make
them and I send them over over a
connection I know to be secured to this
company and there's like half a dozen
big ones in the world maybe a 50 100 or
so small regional ones and what they do
is they check alright these keys we've
got are they definitely from this server
yes and if you want one of the kind of
green green padlocks with the company
name on it they will ask you to I'm in
fact something L headed paper something
like that it probably is still a fax
machine actually which is why it's so
expensive you need to keep the fax
machine running uh-huh
they get this they check it's coming
from the right server they check it's
the right keys and then they do maths to
them and those keys are now signed by
that company with their own private key
which no one else has so now when I do
that initial back and forth so person
comes along they talk to my server and
they say hello I would like to talk
securely and my server says alright here
is my public key it's been signed by
those folks over there and the computers
ahh oh yeah
ok that's that's great and if the
attacker changes one bit of those keys I
mean they're in the computer sense 1 1
or 0 in there the maths doesn't add up
anymore and more than that knowledge is
the the maths not hand up they can't
generate any new keys and sign them
because they don't have the private key
for any of these big companies so the
attacker is completely out of luck if
they change it it will be like when you
try and logging into a public Wi-Fi
network it pops up hey you need to login
we need your details
sometimes that's a man-in-the-middle
attack but they are taking the stuff
you're trying to send to the server and
the get in the way and send they
actually know we're going to we're going
to send back our page instead this
warning or polyps thing we're meant to
be on a secure connection to Gmail but
we're not yeah panic everything run big
red screen which most people have now
trained themselves to click through but
you know
you try okay the attacker can't
intercept the keys anymore not without
sending up all sorts of red flags which
is fine but again all we've done is
we've moved the problem back estate
because how do you know which
certificate authorities to trust and
that's when for end-users for people
like you or me web browsing that is when
you do have to take it on trust because
when you bought your smartphone well I
bought this I trusted Apple they
installed a list of maybe probably about
a hundred certificate authorities those
those those factories on that announced
all their public keys on there so they
don't really go over the air to start
off with they're pre-installed with with
your device if you install a web browser
Oh that'll be over a connection you know
to be secure or hopefully and you
install that you say right I'm trusting
these companies because my browser
manufacturer trust them it's okay we now
have keys on this server signed by by
the factory here and that factory is
trusted by whoever made your browser or
your device so we have this complete
network of trust that set up that means
the attacker can't change the keys and
there are two obvious weak points there
one is the certificate authority if you
can get them to fraudulently sign keys
then all the people that trust them are
completely out of luck and that happened
that happen to a Dutch certificate
authority that is now bankrupt because
no one trusts them somehow they they got
conned coerced bribed no no one knows
but they generated a completely valid
signed certificate for Google they have
no right to do that no permission to do
that but they generated a certificate
for the whole of Google with their
signature on it saying we trust this and
that somehow made it to Iran where
someone managed a massive man in the
middle attack on enormous numbers of
Iranian web users so they were all
seeing a big green padlock with Google
written in it um oh if they looked
through the details which a couple of
people like if you're paranoid
you check the details on this and
someone is asking why is this
certificate for Google
signed by someone in the Netherlands
that doesn't make sense and that was how
it was found out like that wasn't a
genuine Google Certificate but most
people wouldn't know that they're
talking to Gmail they're seeing a big
green Google certificate in that they
think all's well so they're basically
looking at their Gmail emails but it's
all going through someone it's all going
through an attack and the keys that are
being replaced they couldn't do it for
every website but they done it for this
one they done it for Google so every bit
of Google traffic that went through they
were swapping out the keys they loot
opening everything looking at it so what
and this is all happening in
milliseconds object open it store it put
the new keys on it that you've got send
it on words and it's tera it's a
devastating attack if you can pull that
off and there is a genuine concern that
governments can do this governments can
go to certificate authorities and say
right this is the government here um we
need you to generate some fake
certificates or they can just steal the
private keys if they can steal the
certificate authorities private keys and
they can generate their own keys without
even the authority knowing I mean it's a
devastating attack if I can pull it off
can they I mean I'd be surprised at the
NSA couldn't do that somehow whether
they actually choose to do it is another
matter because if they do and it gets
found out not only have they bankrupted
a fairly major company oh no one trusts
anymore but they've blown their cover so
I suspect that yeah they can do it and
they're using very very rare situations
when they haven't got another option
whether they should are not getting into
that debate so that's one weak spot the
other is the list of trusted authorities
on your phone or on your computer
because if an attacker can get an extra
entry in there they can get themselves
in there then they can just generate new
keys on the fly in every single
connection will be intercepted so that's
what superfish did they wanted to insert
advertising superfish was a program that
took your Google searches and added a
little bit more advertising in it for
them um which is a terrible idea but
Google switched to secure searching for
everyone so it's super fair
which ain't such a bad idea they
installed themselves as a trusted
certificate provider and it wasn't even
sitting out in the network's this little
program sitting on your own computer
looking at all your traffic and doing a
man-in-the-middle attack on it and
inserting their own advert that
authority is sitting on your computer
signing keys on the fly which means that
the private key the numbers that should
never ever be seen it's sitting on your
computer and can be extracted it was the
same on every single computer so soon as
one attacker pulled it off one computer
every single installation is vulnerable
because every single computer that has
superfish trusts superfish so someone in
the middle pretends to be superfish
which they can do because they have that
private key then that attacker can
man-in-the-middle every single secure
website out there and they know you've
got it because they can see Lenovo on
the back of your computer in the coffee
shop and you know there's there's
there's way there's uninstall as out
there now the Novo promise them to do it
again superfish as far as I know does
not exist as a bit of software anymore
but it's one short-sighted company that
used every ignorant shortcut in the book
to try and make a few adverts appear
just because of that tens of thousands
maybe hundreds of thousands of computers
I don't know perhaps with a million I
don't know how many they make in a year
but all those were made vulnerable to a
really really terrible attack just
because one company wants to sell a few
ads
you
very difficult for people who go into a
bad place and use a card because if you
complain to your bank then the strip
club or and I want to say we was with
four girls all night and 4000 phones
that's what that costs at our place
how long have you not been recording
that's a really good question this is
because I'm an idiot
ha ha ha I love it with 3/4 of the way
through uh and he says I am not
recording we did that for the drone
footage and schnabel we had a we had a
live monitor on the on the drone footage
with a remote link and we get an also
shopping I just looking ago I GoPros not
rolling oh bring the drone back down
change the battery in the drone